[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
a
oh près des rivières de
Bon là nous nous sommes
assis ouais nous le
ferons quand nous nous souviendrons de
Sion près des rivières de
Bon là nous nous sommes
assis ouais nous gagnons
quand nous nous souvenons de
Sion avec le r portez-nous la
captivité du vent requise de  nous le
S maintenant, comment allons-nous chanter le chant du Seigneur dans
un
homme étranger, laissez-nous nous emporter en
captivité exigeant de nous le
chant Maintenant, comment allons-nous chanter le chant du Seigneur
dans un
pays étranger ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
laissez les paroles de notre  que nos bouches et la
méditation de notre cœur soient acceptables à
tes yeux
ce soir, que les paroles de notre bouche et
la
méditation de notre cœur soient acceptables à
tes yeux ici
ce soir au bord des rivières de
Bon là-bas nous nous sommes
assis ouais nous le
ferons quand nous nous souviendrons de
Sion par  les rivières de
Bon jusqu'à ce que nous nous soyons
assis là, nous
quand nous nous souvenons de
Sion près des rivières
de là où nous étions assis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]